bonjour eric zemmour bonjour vous
revenez aujourd'hui sur l'initiative
présidentielle de lancer un référendum
sur le climat c'est bien joué non c'est
ça c'est ses notes
je pense que c'est la première réaction
de tous c'est bien joué vous savez en
france on n'est pas seulement citoyen né
aussi un peuple siona d'oloron on
regarde la politique avec les yeux du
football ou pas aux amateurs de corridas
et on dira ça c'est bien joué c'est une
belle passe à beau dribble c'est un bon
très bien on se souvient des référendums
passé de celui de chirac sur le
quinquennat de celui de même pour les
plus anciens se souviennent de pompidou
sur l'entrée de la grande-bretagne dans
le rang pour 72 qui avait divisé l'union
de la gauche qui à l'époque menaçait son
pouvoir
bon d'accord tactiquement c'est bien
joué on dit chapeau et c'est maintenant
derrière on s'interroge forcément déjà
est ce qu'on a besoin encore de réformer
la constitution
et on a déjà transformé les lois en
espèces de textes bavard qui sont des
des pétitions de principe et cetera
est ce qu'on a besoin que la
constitution deviennent ça aussi mais
l'urgence climatique ne justifie pas un
référendum selon vous ben ça c'est c'est
la question suivante
d'abord pourquoi transformer encore la
constitution première question on allait
déjà trop fait on l'a déjà trop modifié
on a modifié l'équilibré admirable de la
constitution écrite par debré et part et
par de gaulle voilà deuxièmement alors
là votre question est ce que le climat
nécessite un référendum est ce que c'est
une question assez important apparemment
c'est une question très importante mais
est ce que ça nous concerne seulement
nous français c'est à dire que est ce
que c'est une question que peut régler
le peuple français je suis pas sûr je
pense que en plus
est ce que c'est la question vraiment
urgente aujourd'hui alors que nous avons
une crise sanitaire dont on n'arrive pas
à se sortir nous avons une crise
sanitaire qui va provoquer une crise
économique et sociale énorme et que nous
avons
des jihadistes qui tuent régulièrement
ponctuellement partout en france que
nous avons une immigration que nous
maîtrisons plus qu est devenue depuis
longtemps une invasion seulement selon
le mot du président valéry giscard
d'estaing qui vient de mourir et que
nous avons des quartiers islamisés qui
se détache petit à petit de la
république française selon la fameuse
formule de maquereaux lui même sur le
séparatisme voyez il ya des sujets on
pourrait traiter par référendum je suis
pas sûr que le climat soit un sujet
qu'on pourrait traiter par référendum
dire que oui il faut il faut protéger le
climat mais encore pour vous choisir le
thème du climat comme sujet de
référendum ce n'est pas anodin
oui c'est à dire que l'on voit bien au
delà de la tactique des armes et les
verts qui seront obligés de les suivre
embêté le sénat qui sera obligé
d'acquiescer sous peine de de passer
pour un ennemi du climat envoyé bon
l'été le coup tactique qu'on a apprécié
au début mais il ya une sociologie qui
est révélatrice de dire on a vu lors des
dernières municipales les verts ont fait
une percée uniquement dans les
métropoles
c'est à dire il ya une certaine
sociologie les gens qui habitent les
métropoles les vainqueurs de la
mondialisation ce qu'on caricature sous
le terme de bobo c'est eux qui se
soucient du climat c'est eux qui votent
vert c'est eux qui veulent des villes
avec des vélos etc
la france périphérique selon la
terminologie de christophe guilluy elle
ce n'est pas son sujet ce n'est pas le
sujet principal
si vous voulez il ya deux france ya la
france des métropoles qui se soucient du
climat qui craint le grand échauffement
et il ya la france périphérique qui se
soucie de social et d'immigration
quittera le grand déclassement et le
grand remplacement et entre ces deux
france c'était déjà le clivage de 2017
et il va se coaliser se coaguler autour
de cette question référendaire
je ne suis pas sûr contrairement à la
présidentielle où il y avait la présence
comme mode 2d de marine le pen
voyez pour pour permettre à maquereau
d'être largement majoritaires là il n'y
a pas la présence de manu
la paix n'est donc on aa les deux france
et christophe guilluy nous a appris que
c'était la france périphérique qui était
majoritaire
ce n'est pas la france d' emmanuel
macron donc là ça peut être très
intéressant d'ailleurs on va enfin
coalisés c'est de francs si les gens
vont voter parce que il y aura le
problème de l'abstention
mais si les gens vont voter on aura
enfin c'est de france qui vont se
révéler et s'affirmer l'une en face de
l'autre
et là on verra effectivement parce qu'un
référendum ça se gagne quand la question
est essentielle les institutions 58 ans
sont deux voiliers l'algérie en 61
l'europe en 92 même si c'était de
justesse mais ça se gagne mais ça se
perd aussi chirac l'a perdue entre conte
en 2005 sur l'europe
de gaulle a perdu 1,69 sur les régions
parce que personne ne comprenait quelle
est l importance de la suppression du
sénat voyez donc emmanuel macron prend
son risque il risque de tomber dans ce
que françois mauriac appelé la
maladresse des demies habile merci eric
zemmour